we got james uh is calling in from
milwaukee james how are you
hey i'm good guys how are you doing oh
we are focused to not finish buddy
what's on your mind today
all right so similar to a previous
caller got a bit of a
situation here with a rental property of
ours
my wife and i are uh amateur landlords
at best but it's been
fairly lucrative for us over the past
eight or nine years
looking to get out of it but we do have
a
tenant that's been in our our best
property that we're going to be putting
up for sale soon
that hasn't paid rent in about a year
went through the
went through the eviction process
and actually you know got the notice uh
to serve him
and ended up not going through with it
because it was
february um he he had no place to go
and so we let him stay with the
agreement that he would you know
really start to um pay back what he had
owed
um he was back at work things were
turning around
um but that money hasn't come to us um
so he owes us about 30 thousand dollars
at this point
um and just wondering what the best way
to
proceed with this is we want him out um
but i also want that money so do i is it
a civil lawsuit once we get him out of
the house
what does that look like yeah this is
tough man i am sorry
uh because it sounds like you have been
beyond
understanding like you guys have really
tried to work with this guy haven't you
correct yes and he's made no effort to
pay you whatsoever
no he hasn't paid in about a year and
and the rent is
you know it's a really nice house uh
about 28 2900 a month that he pays us so
right he paid for the first you know
year or so and then he
ran into some hard times um and i know
he's gotten stimulus money and i know
he's back at work but
none of that money has really come to us
so will he meet with you have you
have you all sat down and had a just a
conversation like over a table
the only time the only time he he met
with me is
when i when i showed up a little
surprise visit yeah
we actually don't live in the area
anymore um so it's about a
two-hour drive to get there go true i
mean i got
i got other stuff going on at this point
and i just want to be done with it but
obviously we need them out but you but
you are you guys are going to sell this
property
yeah and and we should clear you know we
should clear a couple hundred thousand
when we that's good
that's good but but from the principal
standpoint i don't
know i want the money that's that way no
i understand
and you are going to have to consult
with an attorney you really
are uh because and and here's the crazy
thing james
not only you're going to have to consult
with an attorney but you're going to
have to do some math
on a what's it going to cost me to
to try to pursue this and then all right
and and keep reminding yourself as you
well know you still have thirty 30 000
that you haven't received and so now
you're going to spend more money
to to potentially not get or get some
money
and so you what that's what i mean in
that consultation with the attorney
is to understand the likelihood and the
and the
probability of you getting any money
i love the fact that at least you're
going to sell it and you're going to net
out you know what that property's worth
but i you know you've got to do kind of
a cost-benefit analysis
on you know in that consult and you'll
pay 500 to a thousand dollars to sit
with the attorney
to walk through it but you know in that
meeting you want to know how do you have
to properly notify him that it's being
sold
uh also when he has to vacate and that
vacating process
for him to get out uh for you to be able
to show it and sell it
and all of those things uh ev john his
guy's been over backwards
yeah the the the chances you getting
that money are very very slow that's
slim right yeah
so unless this person is just piling up
cash
and has zero character which i think's
a low probability right i think more
realistically he fell on real hard times
has nowhere to go
and took advantage of somebody who
wasn't gonna kick him out was gonna work
and work
right after month two month three
suddenly the rules don't i mean
i'm okay i'm i'm gonna keep plugging
along right so you look up and it's a
year later
i think you're right chris and and james
i think you're gonna have to sit down
and do the hard math
the soul math what is it gonna cost you
in sweat equity what's gonna cost you an
attorney
to go after somebody even if you get a
judgment against him they're gonna say
great you owe me thirty thousand dollars
he's gonna smile at you and say it might
as well be 30 million dude
i don't have it right and they're gonna
evict him and
then it's gonna be on his credit report
you're gonna high five you're gonna have
a lawyer bill
right right that's right um at some
point you think of it this way
if there was thirty thousand dollars in
a box two hours away
who wouldn't get in a car and drive over
there and pick that up right so at some
point you got to get in the car
drive down there have a conversation um
go through the eviction process have
that
i mean it's been a year right that's
it's super generous
go through that process i don't think
you're gonna see the money i don't man
that's a lot of sweat actually a lot of
money
i really do not get anything i really
don't and you know the other side of it
is is
james going the bigger picture math of
what that property's worth you are
selling it
um i think this is uh this call my
friend
uh is going to be a lesson for a lot of
people uh when you are looking to rent
not only do you want to get quality
people with references but security
deposits and
you know and it's still that chance you
know there's still that percentage
chance of people going crazy
or not doing what they're supposed to do
and that's one of those life lessons
uh to look at this and so get get have a
consult with an attorney
uh get some guidance you and your wife
sit down and really be prayerful and
careful
on on how you're going to go about it
because what what i don't want to see
you do
is to spend a hundred thousand one after
thirty right
and you know you'll at some point in
your head you'll feel validated
but ultimately mathematically and i like
what you said soul math
mathematically speaking you're going to
look and you go i
i i lost twice i lost three times
uh with this and there's a better way to
go about it and if you're listening to
this
and you've fallen on hard times which is
100 of us
right 99.9 of us falling on hard times
and we found ourselves in a situation
where we need somebody to step in and
help us out
whether that's with wise counsel whether
somebody has reached out and given us
you know we i've had an envelope show up
in my mailbox during seasons of my life
when
people are struggling somebody
says hey i understand like james did and
they come to you and say
oh man your life fell apart you're in
our best house
we're gonna let you stay we're gonna ask
you to step up when
when you can man if you
don't do anything that next month and
that next month and you don't
communicate
someone is helping you out here's the
meta lesson here
don't ever help anybody out and i'm the
guy always running around saying help
out your neighbors help out your
community
and we get a year here no communication
no nothing
and i don't want the message being don't
ever help no are you very hard times
they do but man if somebody helps out if
somebody has helped you out you're
listening to the show right now and
you're not doing right by them
and you you may not be able to come up
with 30 thousand dollars call them
communicate
call yeah i would tell people you know i
used to be a debt collector
many many many years see you come to my
house
but but it is less pd pre-dave yeah uh
but
i i you know on this side of it and
being a financial coach i would tell
people
if you can't pay you can at least pay
attention communicate
and that paying attention is
communicating uh call them
don't be a hostage in your own home with
the bill collectors calling you
pick up the phone call them communicate
about your situation but john i would
tell them this
if you're somebody communicating to a
collector don't try to don't expect
their permission
don't expect them to be understanding
that's not the goal of the communication
the goal of the communication is
information exchange
let them know listen i know i owe you x
y and z
this is what i can afford to send in
this is what i plan to send in by the
30th
right and then do that stick to that but
eat call them like you're saying call
them
communicate on the front end over
communicate as much as possible
when you're in somebody's debt whether
it's a gift like james gave this tenant
or it's
money like a previous caller it lays on
you like that we call that shame blanket
it gets heavier and heavier and the
thing that feeds shame right it's an old
bernie brown thing
secrets and silence it feeds that stuff
man so if you
suddenly somebody does you a solid and
suddenly the next month shows up you
can't pay
yeah you gotta swallow call them yeah
you gotta pick up the phone and call
them let them know what's going on talk
about your situation take care of our
neighbors